as hollywood puts on its glamorous best
bombs may be falling on ukraine
the oscars executive producer says the
awards show will respectfully
acknowledge the uncomfortable
juxtaposition people in hollywood are
very upset about it and i'm expecting
all kinds of expressions of support
to occur throughout the evening but the
night's overall mood will be light the
show's producers have promised beginning
with this year's three female comedian
hosts boom we're already winning we're
nailing it give it to me
the most nominated film is netflix power
of the dog in contention for best
picture and 11 other categories it's
facing an underdog challenge from apple
tv's coda which makes oscar's history
with its almost all death cast
a best picture win for either film would
mark the first time a streaming only
movie takes the honor the question
hanging over at all is will they watch
last year's show drew 10.4 million
viewers the lowest audience on record
and fewer than half that of the year
before the academy is now making
desperate efforts to help the oscars
reclaim their cultural relevance it's
throw everything at the wall and see
what sticks that includes the
controversial decision to cut out eight
live award presentations in lesser known
categories like editing and hair and
makeup in their place the producers have
introduced two new categories which are
powered by social media their
collaborations with
users on social media and fans of the
oscars the fan favorite oscars moment
producers hope to make the academy
awards more engaging and in the best
picture nomination of yet another
non-english film the japanese drive my
car to make the awards appealing to a
more global audience
those challenges will be on full display
as hollywood tries to make a comeback on
the oscars stage
heidi joe castro al jazeera los angeles